well speaking of being outside love is
in the air it is we're talking all
things valentine's day let's check in
with rocky at art house where it's all
about the movies and what's on the menu
for valentine's day hi rocky
hey okay i was trying to give you guys
another test but it didn't oh wait go
back go back go back let's see can you
guys guess that movie can you guess it
no what do you think jc oh yeah
no not yet
come on you can do it you can do it uh
[Laughter]
there you are okay that is of course
julia roberts the queen of rom-coms and
again with the king richard beer um
another rom-com that you guys can enjoy
for valentine's day but for the newer
films you guys gotta come here to our
house this is one of my favorite spots
here but if you want practical we've got
that popcorn candy soda but if you want
romantic we've got that too right sean
absolutely that's you know a big push of
ours is valentine's day coming up and
you know service right to the seat is
what we're looking for and uh we have a
great menu we have a
four course you know wine pairing menu
that we're offering thank you thank you
gina
have you ever seen this kind of
food in a movie theater i don't think so
this is incredible yeah the chefs have
really put together uh something very
special for this valentine's day it's
our first official valentine's day being
open so they opened back in 2021 june
2021 june 2021 yes wow wow well okay so
tell us about the valentine's day menu
and what we're actually eating so people
know what they can what they can get
sure yeah this one here is a the chateau
brand uh palm frites we also have um the
pork tenderloin and shrimp surf and turf
it's gonna be a four course pairing uh
each pairing will have a wine uh choice
it's 120 without the wine 150 with the
wine pairing yeah you can get an
appetizer entree dessert it's going to
be something real nice wow guys i don't
think i need to tell you anything else
about this place to get you to come down
okay only thing you guys have everything
we need for valentine's day except for
the date that's all they don't provide
okay you'll have to find that on your
own i'll send it back to you
thank you rocky we've